hey guys so it's the day before the teen
choice awards and i'm so excited because
diana is here and she brought so many
dress options like i am losing my mind
you haven't even got them all out of the
bag yet hello hi how are you i'm great
i'm so excited
so
many
dresses
and a pretty little purple
i mean this orange
holy crap
i think i'm gonna try that one on first
then i'm gonna have them help me pick
out which dress i should wear what do
you think yeah let's do it okay we need
your vote so our first choice
um it's a little bit too tiny
a little bit like look at this it's like
next next i love it but i'm honestly it
from far away it looks like i'm naked
it looks like i'm wearing like a bathing
suit mm-hmm no like maybe an ice skater
no oh yeah like a little silver skater
it's gorgeous it's really cute maybe too
much for teen choice huh teen choice is
not ready for this jelly okay there's so
many options i love that
you guys are getting a little show here
and even though this mirror is a little
i can see over here if it's a little
better oh yeah this is like a much
bigger mirror oh that's better
i really like it and it's like real
comfy i love the color i do too and it's
like a blue carpet this could
potentially be like a runner up or maybe
the one i love the color in the lace
it's so pretty so this is a very justine
dress that's basically what i wear all
the time all the time oh that's cute
that's kind of fun yeah it's very teen
choice awards
all right guys our fitting is done and
now i'm just playing in all of the
jewels
look at all the pretties
i still can't get over this like look at
these shark earrings
and there's a shark ring
look at that
those are raw crisco diamonds what does
that mean like raw like just they're not
like finished yeah oh this is cute
i love it this look at this look at this
it's so pretty so guys let me know what
dress you think i should wear diana
thank you so much you're welcome good
luck tomorrow thank you look at all of
these jewels you've got so
many accessories see you guys tomorrow
there'll probably be more to this video
and if not that means i went to bed
immediately after it
bye bye